well the president spent several hours
last night in Mississippi on a mission
to hold on to the last US Senate seat to
be decided this year he led two campaign
rallies for the Republican senator who
faces a runoff election today ed O'Keefe
is in Ridgeland Mississippi just north
of the state capital of Jackson Edie
good morning good morning bianna of
voters will be casting ballots at sites
like this one in the final congressional
race of the year this runoff election
has been focused mostly on controversial
comments by the sitting Republican
senator but president Trump showed up
last night and tried to make things a
little more about himself
other than the blonde hair when I was
growing up they said I looked like Elvis
president Trump was clearly enjoying
himself in a series of rallies one even
had a Christmas theme there's nothing
like a trump rally - we agree but he had
a serious goal proving he still has the
magic touch for vulnerable Republicans I
can only make so many stops and today
I'm making three of them so he didn't
dig too deeply into the central issues
of the contest here instead delivering a
speech that sounded more like the
messages that worked at the 45 total
campaign rallies he led for Republicans
this year now you have a president who
is standing up for America but this
Mississippi contest isn't just any
election
GOP senator Cindy hyde-smith is facing
scrutiny for racially charged incidents
including comments in a video from
earlier this month for anyone that was
offended for my by my comments I
certainly apologized on Monday she gave
her last push I will continue to stand
up for the conservative values of
Mississippi Democratic candidate Mike
espy has hammered her on the comments I
think they're disappointing it gives us
a Buckeye again in this state but facing
long odds in a red state he's trying to
win over moderate Republicans and
independents is there a place where you
agree with the president and where you
might find disagreement with him I'm an
independent person now being the
independent senator I do whatever I
think is best missing it now Mississippi
has an elected a Democrat to the US
Senate since 1982 so win by Mike SP here
would be a shocker but if hyde-smith
pulls it off as expected the GOP
majority in the Senate would grow to 53
seats Gail well the country is watching
this one thank you very much ad